chris is there an actor whose work you
emulate his career you admire and you
strive to I mean there's a number of
them one of them I'm gonna say is um I
love Steve Buscemi and a lot of times
like one of the things that's cool about
Steve Buscemi I mean people say I look
like them but it's not it's not because
that I guess it's just because of like
the characters he can create and stuff
like that and I don't think I much look
like him but if I can be in some way
gosh I guess this is like a feeling of
needing and stuff why rack your if I can
be somewhere compared to or be that type
of an actor I feel like I can be
successful and so I love Steve Buscemi
but I like a lot of the character actors
I mean there's other like good-looking
guys like like like even like Tom Cruise
like when he first came out it wasn't so
sure about him but that guy works his
butt off and the bonus with you the more
movies he does the more i like them so
you know I guess I'm I draw myself to
character actors just because that's
that's what I am is character actor are
there times where you feel like okay I'm
acting
get more into the character how do you
pull yourself back in so that you're
just going with it and not quote great
i'm online acting Wow um yeah there's
times when you feel like you're acting I
guess one of the things that you know if
you feel like you're acting sometimes
it's because you're you're not getting
it and you're really trying to
understand maybe what your direction is
or if the director gave you a direction
you don't really get that um the only
thing I try to do is just um it's just
let go it's just uh you know at least
what I found that works with me is this
if I connect with the other person
something's gonna happen and I think
it's going to be even if it's not what
they want it's going to it's going to be
more real than anything and I that's one
of the things I try to do if I feel my
cell phone to answer your question like
acting it's just just relax do you
balance with you through everything that
you're trying to do away and just listen
to the other person and just try to
either you know whatever your line is
react off them or answer I'm just just
by listening so that's how I I guess get
back into it if I feel no matter what
are some of the things that you've done
this week for your acting
um this week um well every day I'm on
you know actors access now casting la
casting and you know you find certain
ways to get the breakdowns and I think
it's so competitive in this industry
like if you if you're not doing it to be
honest with you somebody else's and so
it's it's a you know how how it's what
you want to do it's almost like I treat
it like my business and if you have a
business you're going to research your
product and and and try to find other
ways to improve your product and stuff
like that and um that's for yeah I just
everyday I'm on LA casting now casting
and all that stuff and right now I have
a have a manager and he's one that I can
talk to and sometimes if I'm like see
something in the breakdowns you know I
can call him and he answers the phone
right away and I guess I feel like at
least doing something if he says he'll
try to get on it what there you can or
not so I really just try to stay up on
all the roles that are out there and
just um do headshots and you know you
know do some drops there's certain
casting directors that um that don't
like drops but I've learned some that
some that really that don't mind it and
nobody does drops nowadays so if you
really want to you know waste the gas go
out there and do it you might be a leg
up do you have a routine do you say okay
it's noon it's time for me to sit from
yes yeah every day I get up and I go
grab brew my coffee and I go hiking with
my dog and you know I try to get around
8-830 you know sometimes a little bit
sometimes for online but we go on a hike
and everything and as soon as I get back
you know it's basically a couple hours
on the computer every morning it's you
know la casting now casting actors
access the breakdowns and everything
like that and you really um
after after i get my from that drops
that I can do you know Harper and I get
in my car and we go we go to do drops
and everything like that and so or you
know in some cases you know just I I
make calls to my manager and agent so
and I think they're pretty good you know
sometimes I feel I'm like I'm probably
pestering them but i think that's me I
have to I have to feel like I'm doing it
so it's um you know nobody nobody works
harder your career than you so what do
you say to the common consensus of
people who say well you know that's what
my agent our managers for any people can
be whereas you have taken a very
proactive way what you say to those
people um i guess it depends upon you
know if you're you're with this William
and Morris this agency and they get you
out so much that you don't have time
then you know I guess you more power to
you but I I I don't know how else to uh
I don't know how else to live my life
other than to try to be an actor I mean
that's the one thing that that keeps me
breathing and keeps me keeps me like a
sense of purpose it's just trying to be
an actor that's the one thing that I
that I strive on that I that it's like
um you know I've you know I compare it
to this you know I've never done like
crack or pot you know thankfully you
know I've always been you know never got
into that but i think it's like a drug I
cannot get it out of my system and it's
all it's like a perfect drug because
it's like it's yes you don't have any
consequences you know the more like you
do it's not like you're gonna have to go
to rehab or anything like that you know
it might drive you crazy at the end of
you know the day if you don't but it's
the one thing that um that keeps me
going and so that's why I that's why I
do it because I was in a way I feel like
I have to do it i don't i don't know
what else do i guess with myself
you